At the League of Nations a grave disturbance today
Haile Selassie comes to plead for his lost Empire
he wants them to make Mussolini give up Ethiopia
the Geneva crowds are for him but the exiled
Emperor will need his imperturbable dignity before
the day is over British Foreign Minister Eden
Soviet delegate Litvinov on the left and French
premier Blum and all the statesmen instead of
helping Haile Selassie have decided to lift the
sanctions against Italy the introduction of the
Emperor in English "His majesty Menelik Haile
Selassie, I call upon the first delegation of
Ethiopia, the speech you are about to hear
will be given in the Empiric language" In
the shadows of the press gallery Italian
newspaper men are ready for an outbreak
against the Emperor whose country their
country has taken waiting for his first words
trying to quell the disturbance lights turned out
again lights out the disturbers ejected arrested
and he is able to make his appeal
an ovationyes but he gets no help the league lifts the
sanctions against Italy applause and that's all